Who is
the god like Yahweh the god
of wrath the god of Mercy The
God Who reaches down to unworthy
people.
Well, good morning again beloved as you
can see, we do have some technical difficulties today.
If you're just coming in joining us. None of
these speakers up here work today. Don't know why that's just
what you're dealing with with a 15 year old system sometimes so
the only speakers that you're hearing me through and are worship
team are through the front underneath the stage speaking right
here. So if you're in the front section here just know if I
start yelling as I preach you're gonna maybe I don't know but so you
want to move I don't I'm not gonna get offended by that, but that's
just what we're dealing with today. And so we know what the Lord
is still going to do what he wants to do. So thankful for that
and thank you for flexibility in these times as
we go
But also want to say a quick thank you before we get too far into this
to my sermon review team. If you did not
know that we do this every week. I have a small group of men and
women that gather together on Tuesday and and hear
my sermon as 75% form
as it is at the time and they give helpful insights applications illustrations.
They help clarify some things that
I've maybe not been clear about and it's just a simple powerful
way that they serve the church they serve you and they
serve me they help me grow in my ability to
preach and so I just want to say thank you to them regularly as
they serve that way.
Yes, praise God for that. I am exponentially
better because of them and we are benefited by
that too. And so as we journey through the Old Testament Book of Micah we're
into chapter 7 now. So take your copy of God's word. Turn
with me to Micah 7.
Just a couple weeks left in the series will end it right before
Thanksgiving hints. And so one of the most as you're
turning there one of the most frustrating occurrences when you're traveling
in any capacity in an airline
travel is a delayed flight.
You know what? I mean, maybe you've experienced this that you get
to the airport two hours early like you're supposed to and you get in there
and then the the screen flashes delayed.
And so what do you do you have this reality that there's
nothing you can do about it, right? You just have to sit there and those super
comfortable chairs as well and and try to
eat your fifteen dollar sandwich without spilling mustard on your shirt. Somehow
like you got just wait it out in those kind of things but
there's a further problem here because you're sitting there your gate
and next to you at their gate. They're boarding their flight to
Des Moines and you're watching them and they're just fine. Everything's good
for them.
But that can lead to is frustration though
because you're sitting here watching this happen over there and you're
sitting here at your gate and you're sitting you're looking at these employees
at your gate who, you know probably could
do something about your problem, but they seem like they're not doing anything
just standing around drinking coffee.
You know, I think there's a measure that frustration that we can feel towards
God.
at times
whenever it's appears to us.
That he's not doing anything about the evil
and wickedness in our world.
Like we look around and we see blatant ethnic
Prejudice and we ask the question Where's God
in this?
We see adultery destroying families and
we wonder where is God?
We see drugs and alcohol killing people and
people killing for it.
Where's God
We see abuse and cover-ups see sex
trafficking and we ask the question. Where is
God in this?
We see greed and and lies and
invasions and Wars.
Where's God
Even if you're a believer.
You can be tempted.
To think that somehow God is delayed.
That he's not really working all things out for his
glory and for our good.
Or maybe you're even further tempted to think that
maybe God's not strong enough to deal with these problems.
That the enemy is just going to win out like he appears to be winning right
now.
He's just gonna win in the end.
That's why we must understand what Micah has to
show us today in Chapter 7.
That God's Deliverance is always on time.
That's the truth today if you get nothing else.
God's Deliverance is always on time. It
might not be on our timetable, but it's never
late.
It's been said this way the wheels of Justice may
seem to turn slowly, but they
turn surely.
Pray that today you would see that and that it would give you courage.
to stand fast in whatever your facing
but first as we get into it today, we need to understand Micah situation.
What was he facing in his situation that he
was walking through with his people of Judah.
Well, the situation was that we're getting near to the end of this collection of sermons that
Micah preached to Judah over a number of years. This is
a gathering of messages. He preached and
and what we've seen throughout the book is that they've been building.
These later messages repeat themes that
we've seen throughout the book all the way through it things like
God's holiness God's judgment on sin.
The coming restoration of this Kingdom that God's promised.
Yes. Those are all themes but these themes have crescendowed
throughout the book.
Which my fellow band folks would understand right? That
means it's building. It's getting louder. It's getting more intense throughout
the book.
That's what we're going to see here in Micah 7.
That what Micah was observing in his people was now as
far as they could go.
It says were it's bad. It's the worst it's ever been.
Throughout the book. He's looking around and saying this is a
tragic situation.
Look at verses 1 through 6 of Micah 7.
Woe is me for I've become as when the summer
fruit has been gathered as when the grapes have been
gleaned. There's no cluster to eat. No first ripe fig
that my soul desires.
The Godly is perished from the earth and there is no one upright among
mankind.
They all lie and wait for blood and each hunts
the other with a net.
Their hands are on what is evil to do it. Well The Prince
and the judge ask for a bribe the great man utters the
evil desire of his soul as they weave it
together.
The best of them is like a briar the most
upright of them a thorn hedge.
The day of your Watchman of your punishment has come.
Now they're confusion is at hand.
Put no trust in a neighbor have no confidence in
a friend guard the doors of your mouth from her who
lies in your arms for the sun treats the
father with contempt the daughter Rises up against her mother
the daughter-in-law against her mother-in-law a Man's
enemies are the men of his own house.
Like you see this tragic situation, don't you?
I mean in one way Micah is speaking on behalf of the people that they
should feel this. But primarily he's speaking for himself where
he feels the evil of those around him.
And he laments it, right?
He Compares himself in verse 1 to a stripped branch. No fruit
on it like this. There's just this branch that
goes and you you see nothing on it. It's it's winter. It's
dead. It's empty.
And then in verse 2, he feels like Abraham remember Abraham
and Genesis 18 interceded on behalf of the city of Sodom and
like God just find a few people and they're still following you.
But here he says there's none left it appears.
In fact, not only have they abandoned God.
They've even gone full Hunger Games on each other and they're hunting each
other for sports.
Verse three adds. The people are trying to improve how they
do evil like they're practicing how to get better at
sinning.
leaders getting paid off
great men speaking evil desires
They're so far gone verse 4 says the best of them
is like that goat head sticker that you get in
your shoelace that just hurts like fire when you touch it, right?
the best of them are like that
Mike even laments the fact that instead of what we
saw in Micah 6:8 the justice and faithfulness That was
supposed to characterize God's people instead of
that.
No one could trust anybody else.
No, neighbor, no friend. No family member not even
your own spouse. Could you trust at all?
This is how far Judah had now come.
Everything we've seen them doing throughout the Book of Micah now
culminated in this the wicked state
of the people. We see it clearly which is
why Micah would naturally begin to question God,
right?
Because God you've promised.
To clean this up to restore these things, but it's
not happening.
What what is this Kingdom you're talking about? I know it's
still future, but it sure seems like you were going to get this better than it is. It
only seemed to be getting worse?
People getting farther away from God not closer to
him.
even today
as I started with and
And as I heard growing up from previous generations even
today it can seem like the world is going to hell in
a handbasket.
I don't even know what that means but it sure sounds bad, right?
But seriously, right like it's easy
for us just like Micah to look around and lament the state
of our world.
And you see these wicked things.
And you're sitting there at your gate at the airport and you're
wondering why your flight's delayed.
Like God don't aren't you gonna fix this?
But let's remember something.
Anytime you point a finger at someone else.
There's three fingers pointing back at you.
Because remember who Micah was talking to here.
Who was he talking about here?
He's talking about Judah.
Those who were supposed to be God's people.
He's looking at them having done all of
these things not Assyria not these other countries out there which
he did a little bit. But primarily he's talking to Judah his
own people who were supposed to be gods.
And so when we look at this from our side of this now as we
look and apply these things this whole series of Micah,
right? That's us.
It's the only application we can give is to us today that God
is talking to us that he's called us to be. Holy
set apart to be different to be
a new creation to be absolutely his people
a holy nation for his possession.
Yet as we've said multiple times throughout this series sadly
many people in the church live no different
than the rest of the world around us.
Where we see it all over the place emptily pursuing
the lust of the flesh.
the pride of life
using and abusing people
practicing evil how to get better at it.
lack of trust between Brothers and
Sisters in Christ
It's in US.
And so what's the answer?
How did Micah respond when he looked around and he saw the
mess that he was living in and the way people were living and looked
like nobody was left. He's the only one following Yahweh.
well
He did just like the Prophet Elijah did and ran away
and hid right.
No.
Look at verse 7.
Look at Micah's response.
One through six here's how it's bad and
bad and bad. How bad it's gotten. Here's how horrible life
is right now how everybody's turning
away verse 7
But as for me.
I will look to the Lord.
I will wait for the god of my salvation. My God
will hear me.
beautiful
No one else can be trusted.
No one else is following Yahweh it
seems but as for me he says.
It's like everybody else. You've been to that that Lazy River or you've been
to that that River where you float the tube right? Everybody else is lazily floating
down the current of that evil River and
he says but as for me,
I'm gonna stand against the current.
I'm going to stand against this flow that's going
towards evil. I'm going to trust Yahweh.
What faith he had, right?
You see Micah's faith in this that he was something
we can imitate here that Micah's Faith was so strong.
Nobody else followed Yahweh.
but he was going to
he didn't need to lean on anyone else. He could
just lean on the Lord, but look at what his faith entailed here.
We need to dig into his faith to understand what that even
means because we throw that word around a lot. What does it mean?
Well first he says I will look to Yahweh.
I will look to Yahweh that word means that he's going to
be on the lookout for the Lord. His eyes are going to go up to the
Lord.
That he's going to watch he's going to expect the clouds
of Despair are separating as
this godly man. And and really by the way anybody else who
would trust Yahweh as well. The clouds were breaking
as he was watching for the Lord to
act.
So this is waiting. Yes, but not waiting like you're sitting there
on the couch just you know, ticking the time. This is
waiting with expectation.
In verse 4. It's funny. He actually talks about this watching for
judgment that it's coming but now he shifts to
looking for evidence that God was at work.
I will look to the Lord to see what he is
going to do. Listen to this. As soon as we close
our eyes to the working of God as soon
as we stop looking for him to work. That's
when that door of Despair begins to open in
our lives.
When we throw in the towel and say forget this God surely isn't
working. That's when the door to
despair opens.
Even if it seems small God is always at work.
By the way, remember there's a lot you can't see behind the
scenes.
That God is always at work. And so he says
I'm going to look to y'all. I'm gonna watch for what
he is going to do and looking to
the Lord but he also says he's going to wait for the god
of his salvation.
So he's looking with expectation. He's also waiting. That's that's an
idea that he's saying God's Gonna Act, but
it's in God's time not mine.
I'm expectant that God's gonna do something but it's
his time. Not my time.
It's the same word that.
Psalm 42 verse 11
says as it's repeated it earlier in the psalm
as well. It says why are you cast down? Oh my
soul. Why are you in turmoil within me? Hope
Same word. Hope in God for I shall again
praise him my salvation and my God.
So the picture we get from that word.
Is like imagine an army?
All of them are in one place and they are completely surrounded
by the enemy.
You're like down in this this little Valley area
and the the All Around The Horizon all
they look and they see the enemy.
But that Army knows something.
That Army knows that help is on the
way.
That backup is coming.
They don't necessarily know when they just know it is and so
you can imagine so they're in this scene all the
enemies around them and their eyes are looking to the
Horizon, right?
They're just waiting with expectation that that
help is on the way and so you can imagine their heart
turned towards that Horizon and they're
just say come on. Come on. We're in trouble. Come on.
We need you we need and they're they're looking always for
that.
That's the idea of waiting.
with hope
with expectation Mike is
doing that. He's calling on God to come deliver him. There's an
air of expectation that things are going to turn around eventually once
he shows up.
He's just got to wait. Everything else is out of control.
Even the people of God are out of control, but Micah had
resolved that Yahweh is fully in control so I
can wait on him.
I can wait on his time. I can wait on his way. I can wait on
Yahweh.
And Micah knew he could have confidence God would act because
he knew God listened to him.
My God will hear me.
Now this was not presumptuous.
Like Micah felt deserving or worthy. It
was not any of that. It was merely a declaration of
the character of God towards his people.
that this is who God is
His heart yes was turned toward Yahweh. So
he knew that God would hear him and respond because the
heart of God is turned towards those whose hearts are turned
towards him.
He draws near to those who draw
near to him James 4 says.
So that's what Mike is Faith did.
Right. It was not merely a mental agreement to a
set of facts about God.
His faith his his knowledge of
God's Sovereign activity in the world and his trust that
God would act on his behalf kept him
out of the despair.
that he could have slipped into
He knew that God would eventually deliver him.
He knew that God would eventually deliver anyone else who would
trust in Yahweh. He says God is coming to
deliver us.
And so the question we need to ask today.
Does your faith sustain your soul like
that?
again
No matter what you see around you.
No matter how bad it gets no matter what you think things are
headed towards does your faith lead
you to look to the Lord and to
wait for him such that you have. Peace and
hope no matter what
Is that your faith? Do you have that kind of solid hope
and joy that is consistent or
does your soul swing?
Based on who wins the election Tuesday night.
Or does your soul swing?
In fear because you see these floods over there
and these wars happening over there and you're starting to tie things
together and you're thinking this anxiety is building in
your heart is your soul swinging by that or or whatever else. It is
in your life. And your soul is doing this back and
forth based on conditions.
Remember what Mike is nation was doing it was
breaking apart from the inside and from the outside. It was
watching this thing go completely to Carnage.
This is what Micah's.
Faith led him. I read this somewhere that Micah does not
give up and surrender to despair but he
waits.
Which is the most powerful form of action by the
helpless?
Who Express in their waiting the
knowledge that God comes to them in the form of salvation?
So he could have swung to despair or he could have waited
and that in itself was a declaration of
Hope and Faith.
And it was a a war cry
against despair.
The most powerful thing he could have done is not try to
fight the battle himself. He could have
rested
that was his option.
So again, are you looking to the Lord for your salvation?
Yes, eternally, but I'm also talking Deliverance. Right?
Are you walking and and waiting on him with an
expectation for his Deliverance in
his time and in his way?
Or are you trying to fight the battle yourself?
Are you trusting in your own strength?
Are you trying to manipulate the situation that
you face?
Are you?
Are you wandering off from him because he seems like he's delayed
in this situation.
Listen, if you don't wait patiently at that gate.
But you instead wander off down the Concourse to see what
Sharper Image has that you can play it low. If you don't if you don't
wait patient, you might miss your flight.
And you're wandering off because you're trying to find some other way to sustain you
and his delay has ended and he's
come.
That's not best for you, right?
You want his deliverance and so imitate his faith.
stand against the current
Be steady in the midst of Great Tribulation that's
coming and turbulence that's coming all around you
and you can you can be steady.
knowing
that your God hears you.
And your God's coming back. Listen it is.
It is easy to believe.
When there's no pressure.
When everything is exactly like you want it
to be it's super simple to be a Christian.
But there is no greater testimony to someone's Faith
than when everything is against you.
When all of life is against you, you're still
trusting in and you're still obeying the God
who hears you.
That's what people need to see.
They don't need to see that everything is just great in your
life. And of course you would believe that of course, you're following God
because he's blessing your life. Look how great your life is, of course.
It's easy for you, but when everything falls apart
When the world is absolutely opposed to everything we
believe.
And it gets hard and persecution does come and
things do start to get a little bit unlike what
we want. That's whenever Faith shows up.
But again, you can only get there hear me you
we can talk about that all day. You can only get there.
if you have that kind of confidence that Micah had
his faith was strong not in just generic Faith
but in something in someone.
And in a trust that he was
going to and you will receive God's salvation. You cannot
have the kind of faith that Micah had unless you
know for certain that his Deliverance his
salvation is coming for you.
When we trust in the Lord by faith that he will deliver.
It will always be on time.
That's what we see next verses 8 through 10 in Micah 7.
Look at it with me.
He just said I will wait. I will look my God
will hear me and then verse 8 Rejoice not
over me my enemy.
When I fall I shall rise when I sit in darkness the
Lord will be a light to me.
I will bear the indignation of the Lord because I've sinned against
him until he pleads my cause and
excuse judgment for me.
He will bring me out to the light. I shall look upon his
Vindication. Then my enemy will see and
shame will cover her who said to me. Where is
the Lord your God?
My eyes will look upon her now. She will be trampled down
like the mire of the streets.
Do you see these reversals?
That God's salvation brings.
Right. He says I'm gonna fall but I'm
gonna rise in the Lord. I am going to sit
in darkness at times. Yes, but the Lord's going to
be my light. I am going to have to endure God's discipline for
a season because of my sin and my people's sin.
But did you see at the same time? God is also going to be his attorney.
That God's gonna plead his cause God's Gonna execute judgment for
him. God is going to also be the one who frees him.
from the judgment
Here's another reversal. It seemed like the enemy was winning.
Yet in verse 9 Micah said God's going to execute judgment
on his enemies. He's going to vindicate my faith.
Of course, it seems like the enemy's winning now, but in verse 10, we
see the enemy would eventually be shamed and trampled down like
the mud of the streets. That's all judgment language.
That's all saying that there's an end coming to this.
Which Listen by the way, unbeliever?
You're hearing all this and you're like, okay, whatever. I'm just here because my mom
invited me, whatever.
That judgment that he's talking about is coming for you.
But it hasn't come yet, right.
Why not?
Because God has every right to take all of us out. That's just because he's
holy and we're not he could do that in our sin. Absolutely.
But here's why it hasn't happened yet.
Second Peter 3:9 the Lord is not slow to
fulfill his promise as some count slowness
but is patient towards you not wishing
that any should perish but that all should reach repentance.
See, there's still people.
Who are not Believers yet?
And he's not delayed. He's got a
purpose.
It's his mission.
And so if you are an unbeliever and you're hearing this, you have the opportunity yet.
You're not dead yet. You have the opportunity to repent.
Like turn from him turn from your sin turn
to him.
And allow him to change your life.
through repentance and belief
but this question in Micah 7:10.
Where is the Lord your God?
That question and you saw it here that he's using this
this female feminine language in verse
10 to talk about some figure out there. He's
talking about the Assyrian army.
If you remember the Syrian Army was the ones who were pressing in on Judah at
the time to judge them and eventually take them to Exile. But
for now they were just more of a threat.
But what that Army would do is as they would March through
these opposing Nations. They were very
strong military.
As they would March through they would taunt these
other nations Gods along the way and basically
say man, your gods are weak.
Your Gods can't stand up to us. Look at our chariots. Look
at our forces. We have so many no God
could stand against us.
What do you think they were saying to Judah?
Where is this Yahweh you're talking about.
Don't you see how great our army is we're all
around you right now. You have no way out you have no hope where
is the Lord your God?
You talk about them all the time. Where is he you
might as well just give up right now.
But they didn't know Yahweh. Did they?
Yeah, they could say that to this God and that God and this God and that God and
these other nations and they could run over those Nations, but they didn't know
Yahweh because Mike is God was about to show up in
a really big way. In fact, we see it in Second
Kings where he strikes down 185,000 of those
Assyrians in one night.
And the army of Israel a Judah didn't even have to lift a
sword.
God just showed up.
And said you're going to taunt me.
Show you that I am the Lord of all creation but
hear me.
We can look at that and be like, yeah, that's awesome. It's great story. But listen is
that not the same thing the enemy is doing to you today.
Where's the Lord your God?
Don't you see what's happening in your life?
Can't you?
Can't you see that God really doesn't love you.
Is he not getting you to try to get you to to
tempt you that you don't need to believe this God that
you're just wasting your time that God's not really real. You can't
see him so surely he's not real or don't you think that he's not
good. Do you really think he has your best
in store? Don't you think that's what the enemy is doing.
And he's not just doing it like in your soul kind of this mind thing people
out there.
He's using to say.
Man this belief in God thing that you're futile. It's
unnecessary. You're just wasting your time.
You get your Sunday mornings back. Why don't you just go to the lake right like
all of these things? You're just wasting your time.
Let's go back to the airport gate. You're sitting there at the gate and you
see the pilot and you see the woman in the yellow vest
with the walkie-talkie and it sure
seems like they're not doing anything.
But they know something you don't know right?
They know that the main Works happening behind the scenes that you can't see.
You don't know what's happening. They're working it out. Even though it might seem
like they're not doing anything. What ultimately matters
is what's happening behind the scenes, right?
You know, we love the story of Daniel.
Daniel with his three friends not bowing down, you know not eating the
King's food those kind of things getting thrown in the fire
furnace all that. It's great great story, but the end of Daniel is actually
really confusing but interesting.
But there's a scene of Daniel 10 where Daniel prays.
In the angel comes three weeks
later.
And Daniel Hey, listen, Daniel, we heard your prayer. God
heard your prayer when you prayed it the first time three weeks
ago, but man I was in this battle for three
weeks.
I was fighting all of these behind the scenes
these wars spiritually. I was fighting this King and
this King and he's talking spiritual warfare spiritual battles,
and he's like man, I could just get here now three weeks later.
We have no idea what's going on behind the scenes
do we?
Like I've heard John Piper say this that if God just gave
us a little Glimpse behind the curtain spiritually we
would be overwhelmed by what we
see.
That's the reality here.
When you can't see any results.
When it's different that you want different than you
want it to be.
And it feels like nothing is happening. You're tempted
to feel that question. Where is God in
this? Here's what you need to do.
You look up and you look back.
You look up to The God Who you know can
do something about the situation who you know hears
you because you're his by faith You Luke up
to God and you look back at what God has already
done.
And you think there's no way God is working right now.
No, you look back to what he's already done that he's proven himself
over and over and over again.
And so you're looking at the situation you're like, okay God. Where where
are you? Where is God in this situation? Oh there
he is on the cross.
Where is God oh, there he is coming out of that tomb alive
on the third day.
Where is God in all of this situation? Oh there
he is ascending back to heaven.
Where is God? Oh, there he is with his people
forever. Where is God? Oh, there he
is coming back one day. Where is God? Oh
various standing in victory over all things. That's where
God is.
This is how Colossians 2 verse 14 and 15 says
it he says.
This is how God saved us by canceling the record of
debt that stood against us with its legal demands.
This he set aside nailing it
to the cross and he disarmed the
rulers and authorities a spiritual warfare and he
put them to open Shame by triumphing over
them in him.
Set it aside nailing to the Cross. All of this language is Victorious
language, right?
So hear me if you have repented of your sin, and
you have believed in Jesus overcoming work in your place,
then you already stand Victorious over
the enemy.
Not because you earned it not because you're strong
enough, but because Jesus did it for you.
And if you are united to him in faith, you stand
in his victory that enemy that
right now yes is Raging.
But one day we'll be completely annihilated and set
aside just like our sin.
And so don't lose heart friend.
Don't lose heart that though. It might look despairing
and dark right now in the world or
in your heart or in your family. Don't lose hope.
There's always hope.
Because you have hope that the Lord of all the Earth is coming back
one day and he's bringing with him this completed Kingdom.
Where there will be no more sin No More Death no
more Strife. No more emptiness. No more
mistrust. No more murder. No more pain. All
of that will be set aside that's coming back.
And so look to the Lord in that church.
Look to the Lord in whatever you are facing right now.
Wait for the god of your salvation.
Cry out with assurance that he hears you.
That he's never left you alone. It's not that he's absent and
he's coming back one day. He's right in the middle of it with you.
But listen, it might not be according to your schedule, right?
But God has never late.
He's never early.
And he's never late.
So wait for him trust him.
It might not look like you think it should look.
But look to the Lord for his Deliverance.
It's always on time.